i guess i could put this in the fridge
oh
good catch mom good catch
i got it
trying to pull a fast one
[Music]
what is in this that is freaking heavy
hi much easier
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god oh my god it's heavy
again it's heavy again
what's up guys today is a beautiful day
and we are headed out to vegas it's
actually really early in the morning and
uh don't know why i exerted that much
energy for that intro but uh we're
packed for five days we're gonna go
visit steve and nicky and the rest of
the big mood girls because we are in
fact heading to vegas mainly because we
have a podcast shoot we're gonna go
shoot out of nicki's new house got all
the equipment here gotta pack it up in
the car probably gotta
put some uh some padding in here don't
want the cameras to roll around too much
baby stuff
got quite a bit to pack but yeah so
today we're going to take both cars both
the tessie and the telly
i don't know i just called my car sad
because i don't never refer to them as a
tessie and a telly but anyways uh chan
clan is here my family just got in they
just met baby luca if you haven't seen
the video where uh my parents meet luca
click for last time's video because last
time's video was probably the most
heartwarming moment i've ever
experienced in my life because you know
as a son to bring someone into this
world and then have your own parents
meet that person that you brought into
the world and kind of the whole full
circle you know circle life kind of
thing i don't know just it was very
sweet hopefully one day i'll be able to
show luke at that moment and be like hey
luca this is when you first met yeah
yeah and mama i guess that's the whole
point of vlogging these days is
we're basically creating a catalogue of
family memories it's gonna be
interesting because then luca's gonna be
able to look back
on his parents life before he was born
that's a trip most people growing up you
don't you don't really know who your
parents were before they had you
everyone's parents had a life before the
kids came into play and obviously
becoming parents it's a slow
it's a slow transformation from being a
young cool person to being an older
cool person i don't know hopefully we're
still cool to isaac i don't know yeah be
cool to bailish one day show luca
who his parents were you know in their
20s
[Music]
all right so before we head on a road
trip today um before we bring out luca
to the car and enter this road trip
madness so when i say huge shout out to
helix for sponsoring today's video the
sad thing about road trips is that you
have to leave behind your comfy comfy
bed and we have to sleep in a hotel bed
which in my experience has never been
comfortable and because of that i'm
already looking forward to coming back
home to sleeping on my comfortable helix
bed and so we're super excited to
partner up with helix sleep again
because they make premium mattresses
customized to fit your need shipped to
your door we've had our helix since last
july and we've been loving it the reason
why is because helix created a quiz to
figure out what mattress fits your
sleeping preferences and your body type
it considers if you're a back sleeper a
side sleeper or if you toss and turn you
can tell it your preferred firmness and
if you wake up with back pain and get
this i also like how it considers not
just one person's preferences but two
now based on our results on this quiz
helix matched us with their helix
moonlight now we've had our helix for
almost a year now and it is by far the
best mattress i've ever owned entering
my 30s i i still hadn't understood what
a quality mattress could do for you
until having helix for the longest time
i was like i don't have back pain i
don't i don't have problems sleeping i
don't know what what are people griping
about well i didn't know that i had
things to gripe about until i had better
quality sleep and honestly the quiz is a
great way for you to figure out what
kind of sleeper you are and you know
what kind of mattress is perfect for you
and honestly those questions i've never
bothered to ask myself so i'm glad helix
is there to ask me for me to figure
things about myself about how i like to
sleep they deliver straight to your door
with free shipping and the mattress
comes folded in a box so it's super easy
to set up and get this they also have a
100 night sleep trial so you get more
than three months to figure out if you
like it and if you don't they'll pick it
up and they give you a full refund plus
mattresses come with a 10 year warranty
and they offer flexible payments and
financing so that a good night's sleep
is never too far away i love my helix i
think you'll love it too so if you're
looking for a new bed check out helix
and a link below or visit felixsleep.com
tiffcase and get up to 200 off your
helix mattress plus two free pillows
alright so we are
fully charged let's get this baby into
the car seat and let's get the show on
the road
actually i think everyone's eating
breakfast so i'm missing breakfast right
now let's go eat breakfast
[Music]
hi baby
you have a good nap hi my sweetie pie
hi
good morning hello
hey hey cutie you excited to see las
vegas
it's your first trip
cutie pie oh la gente hey luca
[Music]
you just woke up from a nap
a little cranky we are headed to
las vegas so dad is pumping gas right
now so we are riding in the telluride
and then uh carrie dana and baba are
in the tesla mama's with us
it's always luca so this is luca's very
first trip outside of the womb because
inside of the womb he's been to
texas
and norcal
you want to eat some more
are you okay
i've been pumping in the car
preparing bought a bottle for this baby
okay let me feed them and then continue
vlogging i got this milk for you this is
some fresh stuff for you
[Music]
i think y'all can just go ahead we're
still dealing with luca
yeah so you guys can start charging yeah
the seats are so like
like healthy
all right just fed luca changed his
diaper but yeah this is the very first
trip that luca is going on and we got
all this luggage just for luca just
kidding it's all the tan clan's luggage
too luka's so bougie i know you're good
luca you're so blue where are we luca
do you know where we are
yeah where where are we barstow
where's though
yeah that's what i was doing that's a
dude i go from burping him to just
talking to him to just cuddling with him
yeah and he never burped and then yeah
and then i'm like what was i doing again
he's forgetting huh we're never gonna
leave
you looking at the camera baby so how's
our first road trip going with luca yeah
how long have we been on the road in
like two hours yeah huh yeah it's been
pretty good because he has been asleep
for about half of it
and then he was just wailing at one
point
i could i do he became our soundtrack
for a good while we planned all the hits
all the hints
oh
she was like oh you like that song me
too
let me bravely yeah
see he calms down immediately in mama's
arms
he does
i love that i feel so special
now he's gonna cry
because it's time to put you away into
your car seat
you can't see anything
can you see in the mirror
all righty we are
in vegas baby
vegas baby
[Laughter]
your very first time outside of your own
home
what's it like weird it's like taking
the baby outside of the home i feel
really weird and also i have this
pounding headache that's making me like
see dizzy a little bit like i don't know
i don't know anyway
hey
but yeah it's gonna be so weird to like
be outside of our bedroom with him
and sleep in a new bed
isn't that gonna be so weird isn't it
gonna be weird
oh
he was crying a little bit
he's so cute please sweetie you just
make my heart melt look at our room this
is nice little sweet going on yeah we
got a little kitchenette kitchenette we
had to double check or if we had a
freezer and yes we do we had our free
have a freezer right here perfect
because
you know why we brought this back and i
had to go out of my way to make sure to
get
dry ice
which you can't see in the back because
it's uh it's
it's in the walls of the bag so it's
like super cold everything's frozen in
here perfect hey dry ice for the win
it took us for like a little bit over
four hours to get here and we're scared
of it thawing because once
breast milk thaws you have to use it
within 24 hours we're like oh my god
we're here for like five days so we need
that milk true true throw it in the
freezer now
[Music]
you look so comfy over there
[Music]
yes we're in a hotel room
you know you've been to
a few hotel rooms already wait you were
in my belt
yeah because i'm good oh the first hotel
room you're in after we've been
separated
hey good job
look at that voice
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so look i'm really proud of my packing
skills
bless you baby
bless you so since we're here for
five days it's almost a whole week he
goes through about five diapers a day
five or six times i bought this whole
thing first
and all of his outfits because you never
know with the baby he has a lot of spit
up accidents
sometimes a leaky diaper we don't know
you've done this before haven't you no i
literally never tell them what the baby
wasn't what you didn't do this was isaac
no
i was about to say like you look like
you know what exactly what you're doing
this is how my brain works okay it works
in ways that just makes sense so this
isn't a pretty
i'm just kidding
so i also brought
a portable fan
which i'm a big fan of this get it
because he can't stick his fingers in
here all the other fans very smart
they're like
little fingers can get stuck in there
this is a bladeless fan hmm
which by the way i wanna i'm gonna link
all my
all my faves
in the description you better the
affiliate links you know try to feed
this kid
yeah i also got this we brought this
bottle warmer so this one yes this is
the only bottle warmer on the market
that actually lets you heat up the
pouches directly
so brought this since we have frozen
breast milk and i have my breast pump
and i brought it in this bag because
when we go film with the girls i need to
bring this pump so i have a bag for the
pump i actually wanted to show
how i packed it because you didn't see
how i packed it i did not so this is the
ready rocker so this thing you could
take anywhere with you like whatever
gets a chair you have your own rocking
chair portable rocking chair but look at
how i made use of the space inside so
you didn't just pack the ready rod it
wasn't just a ready rocker i brought
everything holy crap adorable
brush set so we can wash his bottles
nice
also linked in the description
nice and
his bouncer
i
took the bouncer apart so that i was
like oh my god i'm a genius
i can't believe it actually fits in here
and it did
and i was just very very proud of it
thank you
then i was looking at these parts and
i'm like how am i going to bring the
bouncer like where like what bag like
how how are we going to make it work
but i made it work
did i like this
[Applause]
welcome to
mikasa
[Music]
how are you baby
i was in the middle of showing vlogma
how i packed and then everything in this
section
is our stuff nice we've been relegated
to just one side now luca gets his own
full side
what kind of world are we living in
i know i mean
i brought his swim stuff too if we go in
the pool oh yes
so cute
a tiny little swim diaper
and then
yeah yeah instead of like the disposable
ones this will catch us
vp and poop in the no yeah
yeah yeah
and then his own little hat which we
tried using we went hiking he's the
cutest when he wears that i also have
his glasses he has little oh my god he
has sunglasses let me show you how cute
are these
does he like him today
is today the day
he matches himself
he looks like he's ready for the pool
picture
he's smiling you're missing it
there we go
[Music]
you're trying to capture like the best
little baby moment and then you're done
filming because you're like oh yeah i
think i got something pretty good and
then he gives you like the best thing
right after you cut
[Music]
[Music]
you